this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and carcasses viewer discretion is
advised
good afternoon everybody and welcome to
a stormy blustery windy Masai Mara we've
had a massive storm that has just blown
over and there's hopefully left us for
the remainder of the afternoon what we
also have in front of us is a beautiful
cheetah but before we go to the cheetah
my name is Justin on camera I've got to
James and his very very warm welcome to
all of you this afternoon remember that
you can interact with us and you can do
so using hashtag Safari live on Twitter
or at if see on the YouTube chat should
you want to ask any questions now we've
been sitting on this cheetah for mostly
afternoon since about sort of two
o'clock this afternoon is when we
arrived with her and she has been pelted
with rain non-stop since then it has
been pouring down and so she got herself
very very weights now I think it's Kenya
I'm gonna help us ensure what we've seen
is her bottom in a bush for the entire
time and in the last ten minutes
she's just stood up and she's almost
crossing this open area with serious
amounts of speed so she's moving around
quite quickly I'm pretty sure she's on
the hunt she's got a quite a thin belly
and so it promises to be an exciting
afternoon with her hopefully like I say
the wind will settle down and it will
just kind of calm itself because it is
extremely windy at the moment and there
is a lot of rain still hanging about you
can see some of those dark clouds in the
background there there is a lot of sort
of big build-up and I reckon we're gonna
get a lot more rain before the end of
the evening but anyway hopefully like I
say it'll just kind of keep away from us
and it'll rain other places and we'll be
allowed to follow this cheetah in peace
without too much rain kinda mean down
but either way epic epic way to start an
afternoon to have a cheetah around is
super special now we're gonna have to
try to catch up with her and child of
the universe you say nice work finding
cheetah today well child of the universe
I would love to take credit for this but
in fact I have nothing to do with any of
this this was David that found this
cheetah this morning he was the one that
was able to catch up with her in fact
she's not the only cheetah that's in the
Triangle at the moment as well there's
another female with three cubs
we don't know which female it is we
weren't able to ID who it was yet so
this female is one and then there's
another one with three cups which is
super exciting so anytime we got lots of
cheetah in the Triangle is really very
nice and it's probably to do with the
fact that we have this huge section that
is so short the grass is so short at the
moment and that's because this is the
area that was on fire during sort of I
think as July August somewhere there and
so it's the perfect habitat now for
cheetah to be roaming around and to be
looking around for food as well as to
stay safe they'll be able to spot things
like lion and hyenas and the various
other predators quite easily you can see
she's a little bit jumpy with all of the
wind that's blowing around at the moment
it's not easy for her to yeah anyway
we're gonna keep up with her we're gonna
see where she goes while we do that
though Prince Leo Smith down in South
Africa well he's kicking off the South
African portion of this driver to a
rollicking start to the big cat of his
own big cats is of course the in Colma
pride who are a portion of them there
are snoozing under a ton booty and under
gray skies good afternoon my name is
Brent jasmine I have my friend dimpled
Dave the objectified dish on camera for
the first time since he's been back come
back from leave and it looks like he had
a good leave I think he had to come back
to work to get some rest
and we are within calmer pride from what
I heard they were eating a zebra this
morning and at the moment they are
lounging we're not gonna stay out too
long cuz I'm pretty sure they're not
going to do anything on this afternoon I
think this is what they're going to do I
have four they're going to snooze unless
some poor unsuspecting critter stumbles
upon them so we're gonna just thought
we'd have a quick look of thing calm us
and then we're gonna dash towards the
east and see if we can find Tandy and
Columba again I've been having such a
great been properly spoiled by their
antics the end a bit more rain last
night so
excuse you lion it was a little bit of
feline flatulence there thankfully we
are not downwind those feline flatulence
is horrid David is wondering if there's
been any updates in among again or
telemark emails not for a while not
since I think the VOCA was chasing the
Tala Marty
there has been no sight of them
I had we did have one set of their line
tracks and went straight through and
into the West so they could be in the
West with the missing in Colmar female
missing adult female the one with the
hip scar and the former male and some of
the other subbies but the female and
calmer subs are starting to look quite
big maybe these girls have decided to
take a break from those boys and team up
with the vocals for now there's a cap
glassy Starling wandering towards the
lines is him there on the ground David
of course he goes behind the only stick
feeding in a patch of elephant dung
and that is about the most action we're
going to see around these lions talking
Starling particularly noisy Birds
starlings whether particularly or not
the most pleasant singing voice I've got
away from you David
of course the Lions pose no real threat
to the Starling small and get out of the
way quite quickly okay well as I said
we're going to move on and see what else
we can find while we do that let's send
you across to Jaime so she can bend you
a Fonda
hello hello hello
and a very a good afternoon to those of
you joining us it is marvelous to have
you on a board with that us once again
so we've stopped to have a look at this
female Impala I'll explain why in a
moment but first of all introductions
are in order my name is Jamie and this
afternoon Craig also known as Batman is
on camera with me once again so it's not
uncommon in this I wouldn't call it
chilly actually but in cloudy
temperatures with a bit of wind and a
bit of rain it's not uncommon to see
antelope lying down but because it's
that time of year I just wanted to check
to see whether there was any sign that
they were this Impala was actually
thinking about giving birth although
looking at her now that she stood up I
think that has already happened
I think we're barking up the wrong tree
there she doesn't look particularly
pregnant to me or if she is it's still
not ready to be born might be one of the
late lambs you never know but it was
important for us to just have a have a
look and just double-check now that
Impala is not pregnant at all okay
no babies from her in fact she looks a
little bit under the weather
Tenshi quite an old lady who has been
hit hard by the rigors of the dry season
obviously now that the rain has fallen
the leaves are starting to go green
there's a lot more for the browsers and
all the mixed feet of us like in parlor
to eat but in her case she just looked
like she just got a bit tired there but
it always pays to check I don't think
we've had a live birth this year unless
something happened while I was on leave
but I'm pretty sure I would know about
that
whoever noted live birth this yeah it
pays to double check I can't believe we
haven't seen at least one baby that's
the very beginnings of its life now for
the moment I'm I think I'm potentially
limited to where I can go just due to
some technical issues so at the moment
I'm doing loops within loops around
quarantine and the rest of the plan for
the afternoon is to pay a visit to the
hyena day and of course I'm still
desperately trying to do what I need to
do and at the same time of course I'd
like to catch up with Corky and I'd very
much like to see pretty no I have not
seen in a very long time
ah there's about to stop at the
Wahlberg's but the drongos ruined that
for me
they have chased away the Wahlberg's
which seems a little bit unfair given
that this is where the Wahlberg's nest
is I mean it's one thing when the little
birds chase them away out of you know
sort of defensive behavior but given
that this is where the Wahlberg's nest I
feel as though they're sort of entitled
to sit on that tree now that tiny little
bird attacking the large raptor is known
as a folktale drongo and they are full
of attitude and cheek look at it go it
knows that it's more agile in the air
think of the Wahlberg's turning its head
back to snap at the bird completely
futile cos there's no way on earth it's
going to catch us Oh angry very angry
indeed awesome camerawork from Craig
over there he's done a fantastic job of
keeping up with them right and now
the Wahlberg's has seen has been seen
off it's now flying away from its nest
let's see the stronger decides to go I'm
keeping track of it doesn't even come
back to the tree it's terribly I feel
that's really terribly mean the nest is
up there it's up in the middle of that
knob thorn tree although we haven't seen
much Wahlberg's activity from in that
nest this year great scandal of course
was the fact that typically each and
every single year and is the same
Wahlberg's pear that we see but this
year has been a little different and one
part has been replaced okay right we're
going to carry on it appears to be
raining Craig I stand corrected I should
not have said it was not going to rain
I'm just going to cover up some things
yeah just to make sure that they don't
get too damp one of those things we'll
have to we'll have to struggle on I
don't think it's going to be a huge
amount of rain I think that we can I
think that we can just cover ourselves
up and then we'll be fine okay while we
do that and while we sort ourselves out
to waterproof ourselves let's go across
at Tristan in the Mara who is fairly
familiar with dealing with the rainy
afternoon hopefully the downpours there
don't ruin his cheetah sighting
well we have got a cheetah but she's got
the crazy so she's running around like
an absolute hooligan at the moment she's
now crossed off the burn section into
the longer grass and I actually think
she feels a little bit more comfortable
in the longer grass I think she can hide
away a little bit better when we were
watching her cross direction trying to
get away from her and I think you know
even though the promise that she's
running around kind of just I don't know
what she's doing she's just chasing
birds and all kinds
oh hello we are so sorry that we are
going to take you on an adventure anyway
I am Trish Allah and we are currently
looking for Hassan ah
so we've heard that they that he was
seen around the cut line area which is
where I'm trying to go right now sorry
this roads are bumpy we've got these
rain covers on because the weather is
not looking I'm hoping that we don't
have a repeat of last night
now I'm also quite excited to maybe I
mean I'm really getting into this bird
these birds I must say I think at the
more I see them the more I'm absolutely
loving it I have a look out there there
it's actually quite quite much clearer
but they're awesome what do we have here
let me just reposition and wasn't a just
talking about birds
now they look a bit like some vultures I
can tell because they've got this
hunched look that I quite like now that
pole that you're seeing in your screen
is of course the rain comes that I spoke
about before just in case we get
showered upon blessings there we go
I can't get a really clear view but I
think that's a white back foul sure the
most common one we see era and the most
common type of vulture we see around you
this poor guy I'm not even sure if he
even got into the air today it's in so
the way that he's been able to get a
thermal or not but the fact that he's
hanging about there and especially in a
dead tree like a kill around there and
we did hear that the Lions had a killer
well sorry about that guys it seems as
though there's a lot of gremlins around
unfortunately with storms on both sides
of where we are it's creating a little
bit of havoc and so you know these
things do happen unfortunately and when
South Africa gets rain it generally is
those big thunderstorms which means
unfortunately a lot of lightning and
lightning is always detrimental to
electronic equipment so I do apologize
about I'll take you back and hopefully
it's going to work out
okay we are back up and running and uh
some theorists apologies for the
break-in transmission all sorts of
things are happening I can only think to
blame the rain this morning we ended up
in a very strange train of thought we
were talking about the about eating
brains whether or not the Lions would be
eating brains because we were think of
humans this morning and they were eating
a zebra and we discussed whether or not
they eat brains and we then ended up
onto a sort of zombie discussion which
ultimately ended us up with somebody
who'd eaten a brain by mistake in Spain
which of course led to a reformation of
the rain in Spain stays mainly on the
plain and as an end result ended up
talking about a zombie Pygmalion or my
Fez zombie as it was eventually called
stuck with me all day I can't shake it
I've been trying to think of the
different songs of my fair lady
rewritten for zombies you know it's
basically like the reformed version of
Pride and Prejudice only a little bit
different always thinking about going to
fetch our roof at this point I'm trying
to decide if it's drizzle has set in or
not and decide whether or not the
irritation of the roof but it does
restrict us in certain respects we've
got to be very careful with our vehicle
positioning and the poles ruins the
beautiful shot of a leopard walking or
whatever it is that we're going to see
this afternoon so I've been trying to
debate in my own mind if it's going to
stop or not I of course in the world's
worst weather predictor as I said I if I
were any worse that's predicting the
weather I could be a meteorologist
I am absolutely appalling at it
are really not sure at this point I have
to circle around quarantine and it's
raining hey let's see what else we can
find this is now my second circuit of
quarantine let's see what we can find
perhaps we would like to do note the
rattling so sticky ler flew away perhaps
we would like to look at what would we
like to see I'm sure that we can find
something for you on this great vast
empty open area of nothing it must be at
least a bird although most of them are
now sheltering
we're having a little problem with one
of our receivers which is why although
Brenda's dashed off to Torchwood he
probably will struggle until they manage
to sort that out okay
I'm gonna do my second complete my
second loop of quarantine and probably
go and fetch my roof let us go and see
whether or not Tristan is still with his
cheetah and how things are going there
black Jayme hope it doesn't rain too
much on you and I hope that you get to
arraign roof before it does now we are
struggling my seams with gremlins as
well and the rain is not turning and
coming back on us as well and for some
reason Kenya wants to just walk straight
into the rain I don't know why she's
passing all kinds of prey animals but
what she's doing is very very
interesting she's kind of going and
they're just trying to get two different
shots here for you one is the beautiful
sunset that we've got in the background
and the other is an ostrich that's with
her she keeps going past all kinds of
things and she got to all these little
kind of bushy areas and she tries to
then sort of look around inside the
bushes so I think she's looking for
something like a scrub hair or maybe a
little dick decorous dan Bock was
something like that that's maybe what
she's trying to kind of find but how
beautiful is that is that not magical
the Sun setting in the background and a
female cheetah opposing ever so nicely
in the foreground I think that's a
wonderful shot well done James James is
bringing us a sterling image there which
is very very nice it's obviously so nice
to spend time with cheetah again it's
been a long time since I've spent any
sort of decent quality time with the
cheats in fact the last time I spent
quality time the cheetah was the last
time I was here which is obviously quite
a while ago and so really nice to kind
of see cheetah in and to have had a
sighting with Kenya today that's been
really quite pleasant she's been very
playful and you can see look look there
she goes
so she's trotting off now she's not
hunting anything she's just almost as
though she's got a bit of a lease of
life because of the rain she's just kind
of running about and is doing her thing
now what was interesting earlier is when
she was sitting getting pelted by the
sort of most of the storm she was
sitting there shivering shame she was so
cold and I wonder if maybe this running
around under the hood yeah bit for ya
it's sort of serious huntin actually
tries to go after anything I don't know
but it looks as though she's definitely
looking for something in the little sort
of pockets of grass and thickets and I
would imagine that would be have to be
something like scrub his that would be
pretty much what she would go for or she
could be going off to small birds of
some Franklin's and things like that
cheetah will go after those from time to
time too
but I would imagine it's mostly scrub
his and small antelope maybe little baby
antelope that have been hidden it'll
maybe Tommy's or baby and parlors or
something like that that might be hidden
in these little think it says probably
what she's looking for but if we kind of
come out you'll see that the rain is
starting to come too so from the sort of
escarpment side what's happened is the
rain is shifting now around us and is
gonna come along and you can actually
see the escarpment is starting to
disappear a little bit it's kind of
losing its shape because of the storm
that's sort of heading back in our
direction which is not ideal it went
sort of north and it's not turning back
again there's a bit of lightning and
stuff so hopefully you know it'll kind
of just blow over the escarpment and we
won't have to worry too much
Kenya though she seems to be wanting to
take us right into the middle of the
storm so we're gonna have to follow her
as she does I don't know where she's off
to at the moment it's it's quite far
north compared to where we had her
during that time when she had the cut so
in Lauer's last year she had Cubs and
that was far south towards Tanzanian
border now lego brothers exactly half
fast or cheetah
well they very fast is the answer in the
wild I think the top speed that they've
ever been clocked at is like in 93
kilometers an hour it's 93 or 95
somewhere there whereas in captivity
they've gone a little bit faster one one
five I think is is the fastest in
captivity but I mean they really are
quick animals there's no one else that
really can go as fast as they can and
ninety K is an hour is is going some
particularly across terrain like this it
is not an easy feat to travel at that
just and all that speed so they are
incredibly fast and I'm quite happy that
she's not running at 90 kilometres an
hour because to keep up with her over
this terrain would be almost impossible
you have to try always winged cheats are
hunting a position yourself in a way
that they're gonna run kind of parallel
with you and sort of cross from your one
side to your other and hope that they
intercept the prey animal
before you kind of get to you so that's
that's the hope it's often Cheeta when
they hunt they end up disappearing so
far beyond where you are that it's quite
tricky to actually kind of keep up but I
definitely think she's off to something
particular she's looking for something
because you watch how she walks now and
she'll go and she'll look in all of
these little patches you see yeah and
she's almost as if she's kind of I don't
know what it is but she's definitely got
a bit of playfulness in her today
because she's bouncing around like that
all over the place and this has been the
way she's been since she woke up from
the rain she has run around like this
constantly so she stops she looks around
she kind of plays and then she'll run
and then she'll stop and then she'll go
to these bushes and she'll sniff about
and then she runs again and so she's
quite busy this afternoon and it's been
a delight like I said to Heather as busy
as she has been but I'm gonna try just
catch up with her once again because the
problem with her is she takes ten
strides when she runs like that and she
leaves us way way way way way behind and
takes us a bit of time just to catch up
with her once again
and one start trying to give her quite a
bit of a lead space and not get too
close to for the simple reason that if
there is something that she wants to
hand sir let's say something like
Tommy's or grant's gazelle or something
like that up ahead of us then I can
split off her quite a way away and just
go around and stop kind of where the
prey animal is and say I'm not actually
affecting her and the the animals aren't
watching sort of the car they able to
just sort of both sides has got an even
chance of hunting so when she sort of
looks as though she's intent on
something all we spot something then we
give her as much space as possible and I
don't want to kind of follow her too
closely but you can see how she's kind
of hitting it slowly returning into the
rain you mean to stop for us finally
that's very nice of you go
she's a beautiful animal those and she
and she's obviously quite famous in this
part of the world she's not nearly as
famous as what Malaika or the or the
five boys are but she is fairly famous
in the Triangle because she raised four
cubs to adulthood successfully so she
had a letter which was narrator in a
Syrian and two boys and they were raised
successfully and then she kind of since
then has had not had too much luck but
it's it was deemed to be a an incredible
feat for a female cheetah to have raised
all four she only had four and she
raised all of them as far as they know
and and that was deemed to be quite
incredible so she's quite famous because
of that reason Shannon I'm not a hundred
percent sure I need to go and just
double-check you know these kind of
things have escaped my mind since the
last time I was here but I'll go and
have a little checkup we do have an age
for her so I was just going in
double-check how old she is but as far
as I remember she's not a hugely old
cheetah and if you look at the years and
her general sort of appearance she's not
tatty in any way whatsoever so the ears
are in good condition her sort of
general body's in good condition and so
as far as I remember she's in she's
quite young so I think she's somewhere
around 67 but I'm not 100% sure like I
said I'll have to double check it maybe
some of you have an answer for us I know
James you often will you know the
cheetahs of the Mara quite well so maybe
you can help us out with that and see if
we were an age for her but she's she's
old enough to have had obviously in a
caesarean and nerrit Orion for them to
have braids and then she's had obviously
multiple litters and son hasn't had too
much success with him but it's really
nice that we've kind of
caught up with a cheetah given that it
was international cheetah day a few days
ago so it feels like it's a good thing
that we've caught up with one quite
close to it and that we can kind of
celebrate the fact that we still see
these animals of course they are having
a tough time around Africa there the
numbers were depleted and they then kind
of responded quite well and we're they
were repopulated even though it was from
such a weak gene pool that it's left
them to have a little bit of a
susceptibility to various things but you
know they've done quite well in certain
areas and other areas not so well and so
the general numbers are a bit of a worry
with cheetah and they obviously are an
endangered species you can see she's
watching an ostrich at the moment that's
way off in the distance and she's walked
past that ostrich twice already so she's
not just looking to hunt it I don't
think she's just kind of watching and
moving about and but you know and then
here in the Triangle it's an interesting
thing because you know that the cheetahs
of the triangle are not nearly as
consistent as the Cheetahs on the other
side of the river in the National Park
area and it's probably many reasons for
that I think probably the terrain and
then the the shortness of the grass here
influences the numbers of cheetah that
we see if you go onto the other side of
the river it's much shorter in a lot of
the places particularly towards the
northern boundary where we see a number
of different cheetahs hanging about and
so probably is it to do with that the
cheetah here probably struggle a little
bit more to see other predators as well
as to find food anyway and we'll see how
she goes we gonna keep up with a like a
several price stay with her most of the
afternoon meantime let's send you back
across to T'Challa
who's got a zebra carcass I believe yes
I do I mean when you drove up here you
could barely recognize what it was apart
from the obvious black and white stripes
it is what's left of a zebra I think
that's utterly amazing its basic bag of
bones now look at how cleanly all of the
ribs have been cleaned out each bit of
flesh has been removed it's actually
it's such an interesting thing because
it's going through stages first we know
that the Lions got hold of this animal
we know that they clean
love as much as they could the parts
that they like then we know that the
vultures came down the white back
vultures got what they could the bigger
poles then we have the hooded vultures
come down take out these little bits and
now we have flies even coming through to
have a bit of flesh clean up the last
bits of scrap that's something I really
appreciate about the bush everything has
a cycle goes to dust in no time and
after this is done I very sure that
hyenas will come through and drag what
they can from here utterly amazed now if
you watch this morning show you would
have seen that there was a lot of the
sample left now that's interesting
obviously I have James Henry on camera
here he's taking Direction very well and
I said to him I'd love to show you guys
this hoof because you can you really get
the opportunity to see what the roof
actually looks like Oh in any case a
what a track actually looked like or the
foot that makes the track looks like we
always see the track and I like to see
this because we can actually see this is
the shape and size of it I think very
cool and we we know that shape from when
were tracking him you can see the soft
but in the front we often don't get to
see we all only see that kind of I don't
know what you see like shape almost
obviously the smell is horrendous but
for you guys I will tolerate it
those flies do look massive matome air
what a lovely name those flies are
massive I think those are flesh-eating
flies it would make sense since they
seem to be eating flesh and they are
massive but I have seen I've seen bigger
flies in the bush you see all sorts of
flies flies just everywhere but even
they have their base and they're doing
their job
Shannon wants to know if there is a big
difference or any difference at all
between a horse hoof and a zebra hoof
and they are pretty much the same I mean
you can have a clearer look there I mean
it's missing a shoe obviously but it is
pretty much the same it's called a frog
I think that in that shape life under
Todd I'm working on frogs but they're
pretty much the same losses especially
after all the rain the zebra who was
walking on frogs yes I think that's
fascinating the way it all comes back
full circle this was an entire animal
but now just a bag of bones that'll
provide nutrients for the out of the
bush
I think it's fascinating hashtag Safari
live tell me what you think in the
meantime while I move on so we're gonna
make me have a look at the Lions I know
that they're down there by the pen but
while I do that let's go to Jamie and
see what she's got for you that sounds
like a good idea Trish otherwise I'm
going to go to those lines but I assume
that's where they're heading today so we
do sincerely apologize for the level of
breakup you're experiencing with our
vehicles a lot of the time it's purely
because I haven't plugged myself there
appears to be in some lightning damage
to one of our one of our repeaters which
is a bit of a disaster but as you can
imagine it's sort of tall and straight
up in the air on a mast so as a results
that is going to be a potential problem
with lightnings these Impala what if
they were looking at me
right sorry I'm just looking at the
theme Paulo so if you are hearing a
little bit of a strange or experiencing
a strange breakup it's not our feed it's
a problem with the eater so our
apologies there's nothing we can do and
I can't drive around quarantine for
three hours I'll go mad I guess it's me
that they're looking at I can't see
anything else and they're not they're
not in any way alarm calling letting out
sounds of warning if they had they would
if they had spotted a predator I suspect
that the the male lions are somewhere
around here the males that were within
comas until more up until as far as we
know this morning
oh my feelings are is that when the
Inhumans went hunting last night they
said to the boys okay you go that way
off you go we'll be right behind you and
then immediately dashed off in the
opposite direction as quickly as
possible to avoid sharing their meals
and of course is all happening in my
head but I do think they might there's a
strong possibility that the males are
around here the two mundane emails and
the Telemark email I'm looking for
husana by the way I've started on the
West I'm going to work my way east we're
going to see if we can figure out where
he's disappeared to okay miss carry on
they've relaxed again must have been me
okay we're going to continue onwards see
what else we can find fearless
gloriously gloomy afternoon now we've
put our roof on the rain has vanished as
is inevitable
Tristan doesn't have a choice when it
comes to a roof but he does have a
cheater
the Duke it's been a while since I've
heard of too many updates from him I'm
sure he has been getting seen I just
haven't seen much of him lately we'll
heard much of him like I say so I hope
that Jamie does find him he is such a
beautiful leopard that it would be so
nice as that if he did make an
appearance for us I think so anyway but
as you can see Kenny has found herself a
little throne to stand up on and to
delight us with she really is looking so
regal up there isn't she it's a
beautiful beautiful kind of sunset in
the background it's faded somewhat since
we kind of lost saw you guys but still
very very pretty and it's nice to kind
of get a nicer side profile of her you
know obviously with these guys a lot of
the time we don't actually get to see
them in that place they kind of move
quite far away from us so it's very very
pleasant that she's decided to grace us
with her presence and sits on top of a
nice mound while we kind of enjoy her
company I have thoroughly
like I say enjoyed having time with her
today it's been absolutely wonderful now
I'm not sure what she's looking for
though she's been kind of scanning a
Barton she pokes her head up every now
and then and there's been a sort of
there was a blackberry busted that was
here a little bit earlier that she
looked at for a while and then she
ignored that and then she perked up
quite a bit and she stood up daed
straight and was watching like she is
now but I have no idea what she's
actually picked up I don't know what
she's seeing if maybe there was some
sort of animal in the grass that she's
decided he's a worthwhile kind of food
source but it'll be interesting to see
where she goes from here as to whether
she kind of moves a little bit further
northwards or if she goes up towards the
escarpment area it'll be very
interesting
see sky do the cheetah leave the Mara
during the migration and head towards
Tanzania so no not really I mean
obviously we know that the five boys
they stick around they hunt a lot of the
migration but what is interesting as I
was having a chat with some of the other
kind of guides Archer that are acting
gone by and they were telling me that
often what they see with the Cheetahs is
that during the migration period if
they've got young Cubs they may tend to
move away they don't like staying here
and it's normally because during that
phase with small Cubs is that the
stampeding of them of the migration
often leads to death within these
cheetah clubs apparently and and so I
mean I haven't seen this firsthand but
and they say that that's what often
happens is when their mothers have very
small Cubs they tend to move away from
the migration and then as the migration
sort of turns and changes then they
start to come back into those areas and
it would be I suppose make some sense in
that we haven't seen much cheetah action
around and I've been asking David and
Steve and they said they have hardly
seen any and either of many of the
ranges that actually work at the various
places within the within the system and
they were saying that you know they
haven't seen too much now that the ville
de beast has disappeared remember the
Valle de beast have only disappeared in
the last sort of three weeks or two to
three weeks and and now are we starting
to see kind of Kenya Becky another
female of three cubs there was that
unknown male so there's been a lot more
cheetah sightings over the last orbits
and maybe there's some correlation
within the migration being but hectic
pujita and so they decide no they'd
rather kind of move off and find
somewhere else to go and spend time but
it's it's certainly an interesting topic
and one that's I'm sure there are many
theories on I would imagine that many
people have some sort of theory on where
the cheetahs go and why they move around
during kind of migration periods and I
would hope that it's got not too much to
do with the migration I don't imagine it
is a food source for adults but maybe
with Cubs that makes sense to me if
there's Cubs around then sure I would
imagine that that would be the case you
know they try and kind of keep they cubs
safe and go but you know it's either way
I'm not complaining it's good nice that
we're seeing cheetah moving back into
the Triangle and seeing them a lot more
with that big burn section where we
found her
it's gonna be a good place I would
imagine 42 over the next little bit it's
gonna stay nice and short there's a
there's a lot of game on this you see a
lot of zebras there we see a lot of
Thomson's grants elearn topi there's a
lot of food sources for cheetah on
there's open areas and then they come in
see any predators coming and so I think
the only reason we didn't see her hunt
on that burn section earlier is
primarily because of the fact that there
was hyenas around so just before we went
live we saw hyenas and so that's
probably why sir my name do cheetahs
have territorial boundaries similar to
lipids my Stephanie with the males the
males will have boundaries that they
will patrol in st. mark and females do
you do a 2-bit it seems to be a lot more
fluid depends also where you are I mean
play some parts of Africa you don't see
that as much of movement as you see here
and you know if you go to South Africa
the the cheetah dairy territories around
the kruger park sort of section seems to
be a lot smaller than what you see here
although it's in saying that you see
that female that we were seeing with the
the two cubs the one that's got the
missing tip-to-tail she's gone all the
way back up to thorny bush again and did
a big kind of loop around so I suppose
they they can't kind of move they've got
more sort of I would describe it as a
home range rather than a fixed territory
and so the home range is an area that
they will move around in that they'll
mark but as things change and as
conditions change so they will then move
off alright then well if we go standing
around apparently time to move on and to
go find where she wants to go whatever
it is she is quite excited to get there
Kenya what have you spotted see how
she's looking around in these little
thicket areas as though this one if
she's maybe looking for even things like
mice would be interesting
scrub hairs must be the the prime target
sure sure
I don't see anything running when she
kind of bouncing through the grasses I
get but either way it's a joy to watch
and to watch them kind of just sort of
get ever vague sort of Canton and run is
an absolute pleasure they are an amazing
animal to see running and to see one at
full speed is got to be one of those
kind of bucket list things for most
people that enjoy wildlife because it is
really quite incredible you can't
believe how fast these guys go when you
see them at full speed it is
mind-boggling as to how quickly they can
cover ground right supporting sorry
Louise you broke up badly there didn't
get all of that I just
so trying to fix my earpiece to see if
it's that or we just lost our comms
sorry loser you're breaking up too badly
I can't actually hear what you say it
was I'm afraid I'm do apologize all it
is is every little unfortunately for me
I'm not going to be able to hear what
that is until resource it does it's
quite tricky when it gets like that I
radio and as we know bits blinded when
how regular doesn't work it means that
we can't hear you guys mainly as well
Slade goes there like I say it's part of
being alive out in Africa it's a pretty
special thing that we get to drive
around yet and try and actually bring
you guys back oh there we go
movies like what's I got the coms test
that didn't get any further than that
did you say anything more than that
Louise could be having a whole
conversation about me now it never no
would be quite interesting
this louise has been talking to herself
apparently and has been doing all kinds
of things
Louise you better not have been nasty to
me don't be nasty anyway we're gonna
stop right sure four to six because it's
a beautiful kind of Sun set
like I say behind her is and they're
pretty there's a reason why the Masai
Mara is as beautiful as as it is that
what why people say it's very very
pretty and why a lot of people come here
is because of scenes like that that is
absolutely stunning I think so I mean I
don't know there's may be other people
that think there's better scenes out
there in Africa but for me I think
that's serious you seriously beautiful
and one that kind of screams Africa to
me it's just kind of cheetah big open
grasslands and a beautiful sky in the
background
it's probably what most of you at home
think thought of when you first thought
of Africa's these kind of scenes maybe
you would have had lions instead of a
cheater but it's these kind of big open
plains that everybody always thinks of
when when we talk about Africa and when
we think about Africa everybody always
various connotation will be big open
grasslands and funny enough as we know
that Jim it's not like that at all in
fast parts of Africa is very bushy and
very thickened and difficult to
negotiate but it's because of
documentaries and movies and all kinds
of other things that you know we
approach it as just thinking these ways
and you can see just like that how far
she covers and she's not even running at
probably forty percent of what she could
see that's just a little bound for her
that's a little light jog and she's
taken so it gives you an idea of how
much distance she can cover and how
quickly they do it it's really is quite
insane to see these guys moving the way
that they do but anyway let's try and
catch up with her because I feel like
every time she just does that we get
left way behind and then you've got to
kind of bounce our way along and try and
get somewhat closer once again
it's trying to scan around as well as we
going just to see if there's any sign of
any prey animals that she could
potentially hunt so far I haven't seen
anything since we left that burn section
I haven't seen anything it seems as
though most things on that side
you know I suppose I think I got this
the break up a bit but I think I got the
gist of it is something to do with will
cheetah change hunting due to weather
and as that's is that what it was just
double check before I launch into this
okay so hansung behavior in rainy
weather it's much like any cats
they are opportunistic and so I suppose
in hunting weather there's I mean in
three rainy weather hunting with cheetah
typically doesn't take place you
normally see with cheetah when it rains
they hunker down and they just kind of
get into a ball and they wait for the
rain to stop as the rain stopped they
then start to become a lot more active
and a lot more kind of mobile and
they'll actually use that sort of
slippery ground to their advantage
because they have these long sort of
claws that act like running spikes and
can keep them quite safe in comparison
to you know something with a small hoof
that can slip very quickly on a muddy
surface and so you'll find when it's
raining that they'll hunt just after but
during rain for the 90% of the time a
cheetah is literally just going to
hunker down and just try and sit there
for as long as possible and stay as sort
of dry as it can it was quite funny when
she the rains first arrived this
afternoon she sat perfectly out in the
open and in the rain started and she ran
to this nearest little thicket and then
she just buried herself in a thicket and
kind of hunched down and her head duck
down and then she was just there for
quite a while and she lay there until
the rains of the most of the rain passed
and then she was quite happy to sort of
sit stolen and then start to move so you
know they they typically won't hunt too
much when its bucketing down like you
would see with even lion and leopard and
both of those do do it when it's
bucketing down you will see both lion
and leopard actually try and hunt
they'll they'll do its quite regularly
particularly Lions with Buffalo you see
it's quite often with them doing it but
with cheetah not so much they typically
wait until it gets a little bit a little
bit sort of what would the word be dry
is probably a good way to put it before
they attempt too much hunting for the
day so they're more sort of fair where
there should we call it and you'll find
that I mean like I said when it's a bit
slippery out there it's actually not bad
for cheetah they'll sometimes do very
very well when it's a little bit
slippery because it works in their favor
they like I say I have big sort of feet
and long claws that are able to kind of
grow up in
even in the worst where there's you know
obviously a lot of other sort of animals
are yeah like we said earlier will slip
and slide a little bit so they do hunt a
lot off terrain suppose also get a new
lease of life when they're a little bit
kind of what does the word be say
they're you know they've they've kind of
been rained on so they've cooled down
and supposes they've just got a little
bit of energy to burn when it's that
sort of time of the day rejuvenated
refreshed there we go you're like a four
Saurus Louise I just you're a pocket
thesaurus is what you are rejuvenated
rejuvenated refreshed is probably
refreshed as a bit on radio thesaurus
Louise the radio you can almost be like
Siri Louise you can adopt that kind of
Fame you can be the next Siri which is
can be the thesaurus sory instead of an
actual kind of mobile phone Siri that's
what I think it can be the case that's
that's what I would imagine and have you
been called Surrey once before well I'm
not surprised to be honest with you I
would think that that would be probably
quite correct in that you've you know
you obviously a good James Hindry well
that's not a surprise in any way shape
or form
I wonder how James Henry is doing his
fearless leader for our presenting
Department and I spoke to him and when I
speak to him a few days ago he seemed to
be in good spirits so hopefully as well
so James Henry apparently is art with
the thumb keys not comfy is in Shangaan
word for fish which is what we call our
dive Live Crew that's joined us we
called in the fish so he's art with them
apparently and they have very bad signal
so that's why you guys with us while
Coquina is just sitting and watching and
scanning what's going on but at the
moment she's very very relaxed isn't she
she's the most wonderful kind of
afternoon of playing it seems like it
would be so nice if they had been a cub
with her because I think they would have
had the best game this afternoon had
they been Cubs in the third so it's sad
that she lost all her Cubs obviously
Scott was here when we kind of before he
found the den and saw those tiny little
and they meet the den watch for weeks on
end which I can promise you is probably
some of the longest days I've spent art
in the bush just purely because it's
nice to sit and well the idea sounds
great of sitting at a cheated in and
waiting for her to appear with her
little ones but I can assure you the
reality of it is different off you go
carrying on but the reality of it is
different is that basically we spent I
would say probably in excess of 12 hours
a day just sitting and watching a grassy
hill with no sign of a cheetah I saw her
only one I think twice at the den but I
must have spent three weeks there just
watching grass blowing in the wind for
12 hours which can promise you in these
causes it starts to get a bit
uncomfortable after a while and right
now I believe I'm sending you back to
South Africa I must be honest I have no
idea to what they are up to but either
way I'm sure you'll enjoy here it is
it's me and I'm driving around are you
shocked and surprised yes of course you
are you know it's interesting I have
seen very similarly obviously I see
Justin seeing loops very sad
hey one other in my net wars
you
well sorry about that everybody we're
still struggling a little bit with some
gremlins particularly down on Zuma side
of things which is making life a little
bit tricky so you stuck with me for this
afternoon which is unfortunate if you
don't like my blabbing but it is what it
is so we'll just have to kind of show
you the cheats and you'll be happy with
that rather than like I say me just
talking nonsense as much as possible but
anyway it's still sitting with Kenya she
stole kind of scouting about we are
probably thinking all likelihood up
early leave her just now when it gets
really really dark and if she's mobile
and probably is gonna leave it to do a
thing in and it's not race her too much
I wanted to follow her for quite a bit
this afternoon into the evening just
have a better idea of where to kind of
start looking for again tomorrow because
always special to spend a lot of time
with cheetah and she is not full at all
so hunting is going to be high up on her
sort of priority list at some point and
so we can spend a bit of time with her
then we might get lucky and might be
able to find hunting or see what she
gets as a meal it's always incredible
like I say to watch her as she does do
all of these things well control it's
not as clear-cut as what you think is as
much as it's cheetah is a diurnal animal
they do sometimes hunt at night so you
in some areas they will do a little bit
hunting at night so it's not huge to me
as was not a huge percentage of their
hunting time but they do do it from time
to time but essentially at nights they
sleep a lot so if you ask Scott who
spent vast majority of his time with the
five boys when they were kind of
established but when they first kind of
spend time with him he said that they
used to move massive distances through
the night they would walk all night long
and cover huge tracts of land but as
they got kind of to the point where they
were more established then you found
that they would sleep a lot during the
nights and they would just lie there in
rais'd and then they would be quite
active around this time of the day and
then early in the morning just as the
site before the Sun would come up and
then just after the Sun rose up and then
during the day they would take any
opportunities if they came their way but
it wasn't necessary
all about just kind of hunting during
the day so cheetah does ray still on
during the day as well when it gets hot
to find a tree and it'll lie down and
just kind of race there and take it very
very easy but they do move around from
time to time as well right now she's
because he canting away from us once
again he Kenya where are you off to girl
and what are you looking for I'm
intrigued I want to know what she's
doing I think she's looking for any
signs of scrub his that's what my guess
is or little baby animals that are
hidden in the grass a little baby
antelope and have been left in the grass
by their moms to kind of just sit there
and camouflage I think that's maybe what
she's kind of looking for Ruth knows so
if she's looking for a male cheetah we
would hear a calling and we'd hear we'd
see her scent marking excessively she'd
be spraying everywhere she went
and that will be obviously even attract
the attention of a male to scent but
she's not doing any of those things
she is just more kind of moving around I
think she's looking for a certain type
of food maybe she's got a certain
technique that she likes to employ much
like the fire boys use each other and to
be able to hunt down wildebeest and topi
maybe she's got in a way of doing things
as well that she likes to kind of go
from Bush to Bush and she sort of
surprises things like scrub is and tries
to kind of make them sort of move around
so that's what I would imagine would be
the case I mean I think that's what
she's looking forward to moment of it
like I say I probably in all likelihood
going to leave her fairly shortly and
later kind of carry on for the night it
is starting to get quite dark Ian and so
you know at the end of the day she's
also heading into an area that's going
to be quite tricky to follow it gets
quite rocky as you get over this Ridge
where you can see there's a little
drop-off there that's where it starts to
get almost impossible to be able to
actually follow it's quite tricky to
kind of get down into that area so you
know we'll try and kind of figure it out
and see where she's gonna go but either
way very very cool to kind of followed
her for as long as we have and we've
been thoroughly treated by her this
afternoon that's for sure
she's spoilt us with a lot of
interesting behavior now Nancy how do
you cheetahs and leopards compare and
sighs well cheetahs are much longer
animal so it's it's a huge difference in
terms of length so it's a long animal
long tail it's much taller than an
elephant for the most part as well but
it is much lighter so the leopard would
be a lot heavier animal a lot thicker
set big shoulders big head big legs
whereas cheetah is a much narrow animal
but it's longer and taller in many
respects and so in terms of it depends
on what you're looking at which is going
to just kind of give you an idea of size
you'll have in terms of the like I say
the females you'll have the kind of I
mean sorry in terms of the cheetah
you'll have really kind of long animals
tall and then weigh very little whereas
a lipid very thick heavy sit big
forearms big chest
weighs a lot more a lot more power so
it's its kind of game between power and
speed and then and so it depends on what
you want to compare to give you an idea
of how big they are
but she's kind of trotted off now and
sort of running ahead of us she's quite
far in the distance so we're gonna just
try and see I can just get one last view
of her before she disappears into a
horrible section she's gone into like a
little thicket now and if she's gonna go
interesting at this stage she's just
straight ahead I know there she goes she
was running open again but there's a
green thicket that she's kind of gone
into and she's sniffing about in there
as well and it's funny because when you
are watching the serval happened the
other day this is exactly the same
technique that that serval employed as
well is that it would go so all of these
little grassy and and bushy little areas
and it would look around for all kinds
of food items hidden and within those
and it seems as though Kenya he's going
to do the exact same the same thing so
wondering if maybe that's her technique
is to be able to actually try and hunt
using these kind of things and to be
able to walk move around and just try
and find anything Penny's hiding out
here some vehicles behind me so they
were coming to investigate what's going
on so just I think they were worried
about coming in front of us so James if
they want to they more than welcome to
come in front and carry on in the way
it's not like we now that's a surprise
it sounds it says jamie has somehow
figured out a way to find some sort of
stability in her signal and so it seems
you across to her while we catch up with
kicking okay we've problem solved this
issue sort of so I do sincerely
apologize to purchase and we've left him
in the lurch but at least he had bikini
are keeping him entertained I'm back I'm
going to the Lions
I have not he stolen it out from under
trash Allah's nose but due to the
technical difficulties we've discussed
it with them and I'm gonna make my way
in there so that at least we have myself
and Tristan while we try and
troubleshoot the other issues so I
promise I haven't just stolen it away
from trehala so we're going to go to the
Lions I knew I assumed James was ok with
it I didn't he doesn't seem to have
called me or anything on the radio sighs
new everything's ok and good to go
cool
it's too late now I'm nearly there and
I've called myself into the sighting all
right here we go so tricky tricky
problem-solving here a bit of juggling
but we've figured it out as we've gone
along and we're just about to get back
to the inca humus circumnavigation you
know what the most irritating aspect of
this afternoon is and there's very
little else that gets me very irritated
but I oh dear hello hello
Jameses does not realize he's live right
cool okay cool James is just showing us
that the roof was a good idea is what he
was doing he was just pointing puts into
the air that's that's definitely exactly
what he was doing he's showing us that
the roof was sensible what is it okay
cool
all right I'm giving it over to them
it's all theirs which way they're going
nope they're going the other way all
right
Thank You Doki
there's the Lions are marvelous there's
no one else here marvelous
okie-dokie would you look at that flat
kitty cats on a gloomy afternoon hello
ladies would you mind if I do some
shuffling around you just because of
this roof I'm going to come quite close
to you hello girl nice and slow
she doesn't seem to be too worried at
all trying to reposition so that Craig
can film over the front of the car
rather than well it's a bit of a squeeze
it's a bit of a squeeze we're gonna make
it we're gonna do it - sorry Craig you
good
okay Craig how's that can you see there
I can't actually see through the plastic
of my monitor okay we're good that's
best I can do right now and that is how
we shall stay may we go
sleepy sleepy kitty cats a wonderful
opportunity for you all to send through
your questions on hashtag Safari live on
Twitter or your comments and perhaps
let's think a little bit about what's
happening with the Inka humus and do a
little bit of speculation and it is pure
speculation because they have confused
us greatly with their comings and goings
at present it's good to see them with
full bellies isn't it I don't know the
last few times I've seen the Inka homers
they haven't been hungry hungry but they
haven't been this fat now we've got
three a row of three ginormous bellies
absolutely enormous they look as though
they've swallowed a beach ball as you
can see for our viewers who perhaps have
always been wondering about this but
have never had the courage to ask and we
do have lots of viewers who don't
necessarily ask the questions that they
want to in case you're wondering why
they are breathing so fast on such a
nice cool day it's only about 71 72
degrees Fahrenheit or in the low 20s in
centigrade case you're wondering why
they're breathing so fast it is because
their bellies are obscenely full which
is the standard approach of most
predators out here they never know when
the meal is when the next meal is going
to grace them with its presence as a
result they have to gorge themselves
whenever they get the opportunity well
their metabolisms and their digestive
systems are geared towards this but the
breakdown of meat does produce a great
deal of heat which in turn makes them
quite hot which means they have to pant
and cool down their nasal passages
I'm with them now you can keep making
away towards Gallagher which side are
you approaching from
okay copy keep coming along Gallagher
shortcut and take the link to Gallagher
Marty you'll see us from the road here
we go are we just helping a helping a
fellow soldier of the wilderness out in
terms of finding us Debra Lyons do snore
I have heard them myself they had heard
usually but especially when they've got
an injury around their nasal passage for
some reason the airways are obstructed
then they do actually make tiny little
snoring sounds it's not quite the sort
of marriage ending sound of sort of deal
I'm glad you enjoyed that demonstration
I'm not I wasn't even giving you the
option but it is soft sort of snorts
ladylike snores although I have heard
male lions do it as well so yes lions
can and do snore but it's usually when
they have an obstructed airway or
nostril for some reason they don't
really get many sinus problems in the
same way we do they don't get hay fever
or anything like that there moon systems
are in comparison to ours well they're
actually just streaks ahead in terms of
the power of their immune system so they
don't really suffer from colds and flu
and infections in the way we do it it
does happen but it's very rare that
you'll find a lion or a leopard with a
snotty nose but they can and they do
snore they also dream so while we watch
them we can ponder as to what they
really dream about do they relive their
glorious moment last night when they
managed to catch a zebra after putting
in presumably a lot of hard work do they
revel in that experience who knows
do they dream of other things who knows
what they dream
they definitely dream though you know
see their paws twitching do they have
nightmares horrible thoughts of big male
lions coming in and disrupting their
lives or perhaps I don't know what would
a line night maybe apart from that not
many other things that are well a threat
to lions like this the hyenas in this
area Oh big sigh hey maybe they have
crisis of ID they have a crisis of
identity or purpose who knows it's
doubtful though okay we're gonna have to
do some shuffling I can make your way
I'll move back a little bit okay I'm
going to need to move so that there's
that other vehicles can get in here
I think I can move backwards so one of
the things that we try and hoo-hoos
shuffle around whether we're
repositioning in a sighting or whether
we are trying to catch up with something
like a cheetah which Tristan has done
Bravo Tristan let's go and see it what
Kate Kenya is up to next well enjoy
shuffling we've also been shuffling our
way around and tolki Kenya just decided
all of a sudden just to flop down in the
grass she's almost as if to say I've had
enough now I'm going to sleep pretend
it's amazing if she sits like this you
would not see her if you were I mean we
close to the moment we're probably 20
meters but if you were hundred meters
away there's absolutely zero chance of
you being able to spot her in this grass
and so it's probably it's a wonder how
many cheetah we probably drive pass or
leopards or lions or whatever it may be
in the mire system because in other
roads quite far apart and so you often
get this situation I mean if she lies
down flat you would have no idea that
she is even here other than those little
black ears that are moving every now and
then so you know they are around it's
just sometimes I suppose we miss them a
little bit but she's kind of moved and
Nas decided it's time just to rest and
sleep and I wouldn't be surprised like I
say that that
gonna be her for the night she's going
to end up probably just taking it really
very easy and maybe just sleeping it but
I was wondering if maybe she was waiting
for it to get a little bit more dingy
before she moved back on to the dark
patch
I mean onto the burn section in order to
try and potentially hunt again there it
was a little bit easier for her to move
around without being spotted because she
was being spotted very easily on that
burn section but I suspect maybe it's
just that you know she wanted to pay and
do a little look around and loop around
because she went quite far north and
she's turned and she's ran south quite a
long way again so we've gone a long way
back to where we kind of started I'm not
sure what she's up to you know just
looking around maybe just checking who's
around seeing if there's any sounds or
signs should I say off cheetah are the
cheetahs in the area so in terms of when
if he's looking for any signs of her
daughter's and see written and naritai
and if they've been around but there's
nothing else that's kind of followed
I've been looking to see because she
kind of looked over his shoulder got
nervous and ran southwards and I thought
maybe there was some hyenas or maybe a
you know a lion or something but there's
definitely not of keep looking kind of
where she's come from and there's
definitely nothing coming behind us so
maybe just the wind that's giving her
the the crazies and why she's running up
and down but I get that camouflage isn't
that amazing so you can see why if she
hunted in this section could be a lot
easier for her in many respects because
she'd be able to move around quite
easily without really being seen if she
just gets nice and low and she kind of
stalks that way she would definitely be
able to get herself into a much better
spot to be able to hunt who is on that
open area it would be a lot more tricky
but in saying that obviously we know
that sheets are don't spend a huge
amount of time ambushing their prey so
they don't have to get as close as long
as they can get within a certain
distance and they pretty happy to hunt
even in the most open sections and those
five males are proof of that I mean they
hunt right out in the open but they do
also have the advantage of having five
of them which is always much easier when
it comes to hunting and funny enough if
you're wondering about the five boys
they actually been quite busy this week
they've been mating with a female and
poor females I feel sorry for her
because if you look into all the kind of
photos and pictures of it you'll find
that there's
the scrum of cheetahs together and
there's per female at the bottom of it
and males are just kind of going crazy
and a lot of the time when the psyche
that is actually not really mating
taking place even though you'll see five
of them on top of this female and all of
them are kind of trying to mate with her
what really happens is when they
actually starting to properly mate is
that they'll separate off slightly so
one male will go with that female
they'll then mate and then they'll kind
of the males will rejoin and that female
will go off but it's very seldom will
you see all of them in a scrum face like
that that there's actually any serious
mating taking place it's it's more just
kind of the initial stages and all the
boys vying for position in order to get
themselves a female to be able to mate
with so it's quite an interesting
process and and I must be honest I wish
we saw those five boys on the triangle
side it would be such a wonderful thing
to see them but they don't come down
this way at all I've never heard of them
crossing into the triangle you never
know though one day they might come the
side but and they really are in a
fascinating group of cheetahs to to
watchin and to kind of study I think
they sort of behavior is something that
many of us don't really call never
really thought possible and I think that
a lot of the things that they do is has
been quite eye-opening for a lot of
people so been interesting to to kind of
follow them and watch what's been going
on and I mean we ads at Safari live we
had some crazy sightings of those guys
scottson and even brent and Jamie and
James and Ralph and who else was up here
during those periods that's it's I think
that was everybody they've got some even
Taylor she tailed spent some time with
him too so they got some some crazy
sightings and but to see some very very
cool things and those five boys like I
say are definitely something that are
probably gonna go down in history is a
very very special thing that we've had
our chair I don't know how often it
happens to see those kind of things in
GM how do you tell the difference
between Mel and she took quite Ricky in
comparison to lion and leopard obviously
lion and leopards give you a much easier
way of being able to sort of see him
there is a size difference between them
so males heavier but it's it's very
tricky
it's unless you see them side by side
that size difference is not always that
easy
viewable males do have slightly bigger
heads and and you'll find the best way
is just to look under the tail
really so testicles of a male cheaters
stick out like a sore thumb typically
because cheats are when they walk their
tail is quite straight out and kind of
curved upwards and so it's might quite
easy to actually see if it's a boy or a
girl but size is one thing so the males
are bigger than the females and
definitely have a much sort of stocky
appearance what is she watching she kind
of keeps looking in that direction I
can't see a single thing I've known and
we're looking hard in that area but
there's no sign of anything that I can
see at all so I don't know what she's
seeing that we are not maybe something
way in the distance the eyesight is
incredible these animals see a lot
better than what we do that's for sure
and so maybe she spotted something way
off that she's a bit kind of nervy about
and is rather just gonna allow it to
come closer before she decides what
she's actually going to do right will
sit with her I think we've probably got
about another 10 or so minutes that
we'll be able to spend with her before
it gets too dark and we're going to just
end up kind of shining lights and like
doing the right thing and so before that
happens though let's send you back
across to Jamie who's got the implement
prior to it sounds like they arrived
been moving from their own accord they
are up and about
interestingly enough it just goes to
show how opportunistic lions are a herd
of Impala nearly walked right into the
middle of the pride of enormous and
attracted the attention of the some of
the lionesses who got up and went
straight into stock mode now you'll
notice every now and again that we
struggle to follow them that's of course
because we have a roof on even though
it's not raining I don't want to talk
about it anymore
well the lioness is making her way down
to where those Impala were very softly
here's the ridge nose - she also wants
to get involved sorry about the pole
everyone just one of those things and
it's a bit of a tight squeeze in here
are we going to go that way nope we are
going to stop right here and urinate no
no Impala for you okay Oh shame they've
disturbed a hiccup sorry Mike hold on
I'm just try and see if we can see this
I don't think we're going to be able to
sorry girl but there's a thick knee
that's been flushed out by the lion can
you see it there Craig or as a - it's
gonna be a bit of a messy Macy
experience it's there there it is that's
it over there it's been flushed out by
the Lions we don't usually get to see
them at this time of day
they're nocturnal Birds as you go as the
lioness here comes amber eyes oh my girl
Oh shame that the cops are so upset I
can just hear them skulking they're not
called the cops anymore the culprit
means I must have a nest in there I bet
you they do I can't move at the moment
unfortunately I would like to reposition
because it does look like these
lionesses are going to go and hunt here
comes the lioness that's blind in one
eye you should not blind actually I
don't know if she's fully blind here she
goes
oh we were gonna ask the answer the
question about the dynamics that we have
here yes we have four adult lionesses
and just one of the sub adults one of
the females come on then
rich noise you were the one who was the
most keen are you going Yes No
looking at us Oh roof left slightly in
the breeze
all righty now it's time to follow along
I think they're going to hunt the Impala
but there's nothing I can do until the
other two vehicles move so we just have
to sit patiently until we can
someone's feeling not up to the up to
the hunt this afternoon not interested
at all here they've gone Craig sorry I'm
gonna lean forward into over and into
your shots it's the only way I can see I
just want to get a direction here no
they've got right down into the drainage
cool how's it going
oh are you hey one of the vehicles is
having a little bit of a problem getting
back out of this situation so we're
going to we're going to try and catch up
with the Akuma's and see if we can help
them out while we do that we'll send you
across to a tristan in the masai mara
who is hopefully still with it Kenya
well good luck Jamie I know those in
coomer's can be into it super you
sometimes when they go through the
thicket so hopefully you'll be able to
keep up with him as you can see me with
our salad cutters I've no nickname - a
salad cap because she's just eating
grass and she's not licking her lips
after her little salad that she ate off
the top of that mound of went up there
and was grazed new hinges off the top
and is now looking very smug with
herself yes you're a pretty girl aren't
you she's a beautiful cat and seriously
I've enjoyed like I say my officer noon
hopefully you guys have - its way
special like I said to spend some time
with and cheetah you know and you know
we say lucky that we spend so much time
with leopard and you know as much with
lions but you know we see a lot of those
two bits yeah with cheetah you know we
haven't really had that much lately and
so it's such a privilege to be able to
spend a lot of time with a cheetah once
again so I've thoroughly enjoyed my
afternoon like I said hopefully you guys
have - and we're off back the exact way
we came so the way that she's walking
now this is the exact direction that we
drove him to get to the point that we
did she's lay on top of her mom decided
no she does want to go that way anymore
and now we going back all the way the
same direction to where we originally
started which is a long long long long
way away from where we are now the road
is pretty distant so if you look on the
horizon that's where the road is that's
how far we've got to go off the road in
order to be get what to get with her and
follow her now we've got to get all the
way back to that section to get onto the
road once
it's going to be a bumpy little longer
sort of journey back and like I say it
is starting to get dark you can see it's
getting a bit dingy now and so like I
mean as much as we probably could follow
it but you know here and tomorrow there
isn't any of those rules that that we
should leave cheaters who I just you
know she's given us so much already
during the course of the afternoon we've
been with her since two o'clock this
afternoon so you know we've spent a good
sort of six hours
well maybe not six hours what is the
time now six o'clock now I don't even
know what the time is it to be honest
with you guys
my watch broke off the day before I left
which I'm very sad about so a lot of you
will know that I wear a watch every
single day and half plus six hour time
yes what is that that's yes six hours
basically there's no four hours three or
four hours that we've been with it so a
lot of you will know that I wear watch
every day and it's it's Murphy's Law
it's common well not comment but it's
mere physical brains and I were having a
conversation when we were on leave and I
was saying no that my watch has really
stood up to the taste of time and it has
been through abuse it's it's about ten
years old that watching and has had an
absolute pounding in its life it's been
through everything you can imagine a
day-to-day basis and I don't take it off
so it kind of gets absolutely hammered
but anyways so Ben said he would manage
to break it in a few days because he's
so hard on watches and you know brains
he Mandy Smith is one that just breaks
everything apparently and so yeah
thoughts myself on earth fine it's all
works and it's got a titanium band that
render wall I don't know if you can call
it a band is it a band if it's got
little links in it I don't know you
strap whatever you want to call it yeah
so it has a titanium and abandon it's
and so what I did is I thought well I'll
be fine with it everything will be good
and then the little link broke and so I
went to try to get it fixed because it
broke halfway through the day and I went
to try get it fixed and they said they
couldn't fix it before my departure time
that evening and so my poor watch is
still sitting at the Judah and I'm
timeless should I say yes which is
depressing in many respects I keep
looking and seeing no watching then
panicking and then what so randomly
because you know the weight of a watch
is always kind of there and so I keep
feeling like it's not it's too lights
and then I don't panic because I think
it's
falling off somewhere and then I
remember no actually it's just being
fixed and that's I'll get it back when I
get back but it's a horrible feeling and
then I'm gonna have to get used to it
again by the time I get back I'll be
used to not wearing one and these are
the struggles that all my life at the
moment I know not very much problem but
such is the case right let's catch up
with Kenya for one last view because it
is getting very dark now and so I'm not
like I say gonna stay with it too much
time guys gonna get one last view
and I Lauren I decided Christmas gift
ends to be honest with you I I finally
enjoy my watch the one that I've caught
and I don't really want another one
until we understand quite happy with the
one that I have I thoroughly like I say
I enjoy it and it makes me happy so are
you going to climb a tree for us climb
the tree for us do it do it look at the
tree and climb its come on come on you
know you want to yes you looking at it
come on up you go ah she had a brief
thought about it didn't she she kind of
looked at it as if to say mm maybe I
should go up the tree and have this sort
of indulge these people that then she
realized no that's just too much if it's
and so she stopped and didn't grab the
tree which is very sad for us because it
would have been nice to have it cheetah
climbing a tree I've seen her in trees
before um funny enough she they used to
be a tree near in tin that she climbed
every now and then and she used to peer
art so it's been I think you saw a lot
of you would have seen that footage that
we recorded that day but she might go up
this one let's just have a little look
she doesn't go up it she'll st. markets
one oh it's gonna be either one it's
gonna happen this one's got a nice
little sort of kind of V in it and
sometimes whether it comes to kind of
climbing trees for cheetah they're
looking for a certain sort of shape of a
tree and that's not too high but
something else has caught her attention
she's sniffing around there whenever
another Cheetahs been here look you see
how she's smelling she's really kind of
giving a good sniff to the grass there
and is now rolling in it hmm I wonder
now if another cheetah female has walked
through yeah because that's exactly
where she started sniffing and she's now
rolling around and basically marking it
herself by rubbing her face she's
putting her body all over that same
piece of grass and I wouldn't be
surprised she stands up in urinates on
it before she leaves this area but
definitely something piqued her interest
in terms of smell and now she is
thoroughly making sure that her scent is
all over that piece of grass either it's
a male that's marked and she wants to
come into a nice truss when start
marking or it's a female that's been
through there which would I suppose
makes sense I don't know if there's been
any males in this area of late um I
really am not sure but she theoretically
should be starting to come into Easter
cycles she lost her Cubs all the way
back in
August September somewhere there no
christening in was when did I leave the
Myra no July July was when she lost the
Cubs and so she should be coming it's
Easter cycles or should have already and
been mating so it'll be interesting to
see what she's actually up to but she
definitely marking a bit of Turkey did
you get a fright with yourself funny cat
are you gonna go up the tree you look
like you wanna go up the tree sorry
Louise we going to wait for two seconds
to see if she goes up and I'm supposed
to send you guys to Jamie but I want to
see if the cheated crimes the tree god
the tree go go go
no scent marking it's nothing about it's
clearly something of interest has marked
this tree I would imagine it would be
another cheating all right are we going
to leave her there she bounds away into
the darkness and while we do that we're
going to carry on towards the road to
try and get ourselves out of this
thicket as well
we're not thicket but out of this sort
of area and onto actual decent Road and
while we do that's to send you back to
Jamie who's still keeping up a thinkin
maybe go we've managed to catch up with
the inca homer pride and whatever
happened without it those Impala
i think it was very brief ER I don't
even think that they've bothered to go
and see if they can stalk them I haven't
heard any sounds of Impala in distress
or alarm calling the Lions at the moment
seem to be a little bit at a loss as to
what they really want to do some of them
have moved into a very dense area around
the Gallagher lodge it's basically a
temporary thicket and they seem to be
making their way in there the rest of
them are on the road in front of us I'm
gonna reposition now actually put myself
here because I thought they were going
to come and have another drink at the
water hole but they haven't done that so
let's just shuffle around so we can get
a bit of you
get a bit closer to the others in a bit
I'm just gonna try see where they're off
to a might be having a drink in the
puddle up ahead I think that they are
okay there we go
this was the lioness that was next to us
when we first went to reposition he's
now caught up with the rest of them
she's exhausted it is it's exhausting
work digesting all that food well the
ever had a long long very large meal hmm
new egg is walk stood at the end of it
and you just want to go and sleep
because all of the blood is in your
digestive tract that's what these Lions
feel like right now
they cannot cannot focus on anything
else Lou says that that's how she felt
after Trish allas curry Trish Ollie very
kindly made us the most delectable curry
oh it was yummy it was so so yummy so I
completely understand where Lou is
coming from I think actually I went home
shortly after that and was asleep within
about two seconds so I understand
exactly what Lou means
Oh Adele ass always a tricky one I don't
want to know how you tell the difference
between a full or a pregnant lion it's
only in the late stages of pregnancy
that you really start to see the line is
showing the frequency tends to set a bit
further back than a food baby so it's
back sort of towards between the back
legs there's a bit more of a bulge at
this you know at the moment these
lionesses look as though they've
swallowed a beach ball and when she gets
up there night you'll be able to see
it's sort of a very clear round curve
they've got proper curved bellies but
when a lioness is pregnant the the skin
sort of all the the the the stomach
towards the back towards the back legs
hangs a lot lower so it's not quite the
same shape I always find it very
difficult particularly when you're
dealing with a line that is full because
of course then there they can actually
you can't quite work out whether or not
has a pregnant lion or not yeah there we
go there's one that's coming along here
hopefully she'll give us a side view of
her belly Nikki there you can see it
droops very clearly down in the middle
it's very round we're with a pregnant
lioness it's it's it's further the Bulge
but it's further towards the back legs
that's the one of the one of the bite
marks no yes it is I think judging by
the way that she's walking one of them's
got two puncture wounds on the back of
her leg that she's had for quite a while
okay I'm going to reposition because
they are drinking which I would like to
see
oh my girl here we go I'm just duck down
out of the way I'm not blocking the
other line s so she should be fine
I have an awkward angle but there we go
so that this line s is the one that has
already quenched our thirst then the
other two have moved to her saunas
puddle over there and that's where
they're drinking from so they haven't
actually gone to the Gallagher waterhole
itself now contentedly sipping away from
a slightly fresher puddle Paula Lyons
weren't really vomit if they eat too
much they they don't have the same
concept of too much in the same way that
you and I might do they cannot eat to
the point of vomiting but they will form
it if they've eaten something that
doesn't quite agree with them something
perhaps like a for example like a like a
hoof or a piece of bone that's a little
bit too large to digest and at which
point they will actually vomit
what they'll do is they usually go and
they eat a little bit of grass and then
they vomited up
not so long ago actually saw some of her
saunas vomit you know that also makes
sense I'm sorry to go back to this I've
just realized something we saw when we
started off our morning when we saw her
sauna on foot we've started with a pile
of vomit and it was only afterwards that
we'd realized that he'd had a narrow
escape from the lion and I've just
realized of course he vomited
he was probably absolutely terrified Oh
shame
it didn't occur to me at the time during
the sort of the surprise of learning
that husana had had a close encounter
with a lion I didn't even I didn't even
think or connect the two sorry
completely different train of thought it
just that conversation about vomiting
triggered that memory ok Lions now you
back on the side of me all right
adle lions definitely do want to drink
want to drink more when they've had a
big meal they're actually quite capable
of going for a day or two without water
but they prefer not to so if there's
water available they will drink and they
will definitely drink more when they are
full bellied just helps the digestive
process either line on the right that's
the one with it that's purple eye we
call it and it's easy to see why I have
no idea what happened to her so the one
that we're missing is the one with the
big scar on her hip and of course the
rest of the sub-adults
and a pretty girl what have you seen
listening intently they're quite active
for very flat lines she's going to go
and come and sit with the rest of the
pride when she moves fast us then we'll
move a little bit so that we can see the
rest of them
and head rub
now Shannon you want to know why the big
cats don't have slits pupils like
domestic cats do I have to be honest I'm
not a hundred percent sure exactly what
the reason is for that
which way'd which way are you going
being that way are you coming this way
I'm actually not 100% sure I mean we can
let's have a nice close look at their
eyes hello amber and we can have a look
and think about it I wonder if it's not
to do I mean caps night vision is enjoy
guys
cats night vision is supreme but I mean
that applies to domestic cats as well as
to the big cats I mean remember that
there are some differences there
although they're all part of the Phelan
family there are completely different
genus so perhaps it's just that there's
a be an entirely separate evolutionary
design to their eyes which has led to
them having round pupils that expand in
a different way to that of the slit-like
pupils of a domestic cat 100% sure look
it up don't think there's much
information on it I mean the slit seems
to work just as well as the tiny dot for
reducing the amount of light because of
course that's the way that all eyes and
the design of an eye allows it to
compensate for changes in light if it's
very bright then obviously the opening
is very very small so that not too much
light goes in and over stimulates the
photoreceptors but if it is very dark
and obviously the opening is as wide as
possible to allow for as much light as
possible but both cats and big cats and
domestic cats have exceptional night
vision don't you think about cheetahs
pupils no Gigi have also got dots they
don't have slit eyes or slit pupils
whatever the explanation it'll never be
as odd as the rectangular design of a
goat's pupil or a mongoose that's
disconcerting
and we're back to flat-ish flattish now
talking about the night vision of a lion
imagine how amazing it would be to be
able to see in the dark in the way that
they do now of course it comes with its
swings and roundabouts so we are able to
see in greater detail in full sort of an
almost full color spectrum or what we
think of as a full color spectrum of
courses other so the colors to see we
don't have UV vision in the same way
some insects do but now Lions of course
don't they they can't see color but not
many colors and it's most of it is sort
of very dull in their vision their
daytime vision they don't see the same
detail that we do but at night it's an
entirely different story and their night
vision is essentially the same almost
the same as their day vision which of
course allows them to capitalize on the
coat of darkness that is lent to the
African wilderness when when the Sun has
set she's almost like she's listening to
bird sounds in the frogs
I often wish that I've spoken about this
before on multiple occasions oh we're
going back again now okay on multiple
occasions I've mentioned that I would
love to be able to live in an animal's
brain for a day just to experience what
it must be like to be them to here in
the way that they do to have that
imagine imagine being able to hear
things in the way that they hear things
imagine what she's experiencing of the
world right now and that applies to
smell as well so she's I'm just don't
see what she's up to she's getting she
is lying down again so she's smelling
every single animal that's been past
this area since well probably since the
rain oh just hold on one moment just
gonna listen to the Impala alarm calls I
can hear some things that's a male being
silly rutting or trying to rut which
isn't going to work very well because no
the females are in East hrus but how
cool it would be be an elephant for a
day and feel what it feels like to have
a trunk being lion for a day and know
what it feels like to be as powerful
more Lifford and be as agile and still
experience what it's what it's like to
have a completely different foot
structure with all of your tassels and
carpals extended I would love to be able
to do that of course he's a pipedream
and will never ever happen but it would
be very cool if it did okay since we're
having a joyful drive with Tristan and
myself a time for you to tell me which
animal if you could only choose one
which animal you'd like to enter the
mind of an experience just for 24 hours
you can send that through on hashtag
Safari live on Twitter alternatively in
the YouTube comments chat stream what
animal would you be if you could be in
the mind of an animal not you you'd be
the animal but just for a day and you
get to experience everything in the way
that they do
I never be very disconcerting if when
you return to your human state you'd
feel this powerful desire to if you were
an elephant swing your nose backwards
and forwards take a while you know I
suppose that the animal spent its whole
life learning to be coordinated anyway
let's not overcomplicate this that is
very cool Lily who is seven years old is
on it she has answered us she's let us
know that she would like to be either a
fish eagle or a cheetah imagine soaring
Lily taking to the skies and feeling
what it feels like to be able to fly and
have wings or maybe feel what it feels
like to be a cheetah and run in the way
that they do to be able to reach those
speeds using your own legs would be
absolutely awesome I think those are
very good choices Lily I agree with them
completely I didn't even think of what
it must be like to be a bird in my
conversation now imagine being a bird
you'd have such good eyesight you could
spot all sorts of things from the air
here we go Nona's got tired of being on
a tone Alice has said that she would
like to be a black mama
okay Alice fair enough fair enough
gosh what an interesting experience that
would be you would definitely be able to
taste smells and feel vibrations in a
way that we're completely unaware of
you'd have the power of movement moving
like a snake must be an amazing feeling
sinuous we actually Craig and I did see
a snake earlier looked like a little
spitting cobra but it was so quick
rocki night says that he would like to
be his own dog well fair enough fair
enough rocky I imagine that that would
be quite an experience as well I don't
know what type of dog you have but
either way that sense of smell and
having a tail that wags when you're
happy mm-hmm I don't know if your dog is
allowed on the furniture or not but it
might be quite nice to be a dog for a
day you know you get up go and sniff
things go and lie down on the couch or
the bed or the floor depending upon
where you're allowed to be lying a patch
of Sun yeah might actually be quite nice
to be somebody's pet cats as well
somebody feeds you not that we don't get
rid of camp so I really shouldn't
complain
ah well I have marvelous news news that
will astound and delight you news that
will send you into a paroxysm of joy
branches out in about and he's with
Clallam indeed we are we have found the
little princess atop a termite area
waiting for mom we were quite confident
she was she would be cut in this area
where while Costa where the kill was
yesterday morning even though I linked
and gone I got the the male's share last
night and Tandy is moved off there is no
reason for Tomba to one that too far so
we took us a wild finder
we checked many different termite mounds
we checked in the little dry riverbed we
checked on first rock but eventually we
found her not far away up towards the
crest on a lovely termite mound and of
course she was looking at us earlier she
has now decided we're not that
interesting here we should try to move
around to the other side and every what
do you think
of course of course
little little nonsense looking quite
content to snooze but we don't know how
playful she can be so we are hoping and
if we spend a bit of time with that she
will I hopefully get up and go for a
wonder Brent
hello Bridge and sprint speaking Brent
says this has been cat filled drive well
indeed it has Oh Sean look at it it's so
sweet when it's sleeping
very very relaxed little kitty she must
be absolutely loving this weather choose
to the fact that that the biting flies
and other creatures like that I'm not
going to be giving her too much hassle
in this cool weather
magic dragon wizard says since this is
the area where Tandy leaves columbic
regularly do we think that this might
possibly be the area that Tandy will
sequest off to her as territory when she
does decide to leave camp I learn
completely it's possible I think it's
quite strongly possible that this center
of Torchwood might become little
Columbus the lumbers hood so to speak ah
shame come on it's time to go wandering
we're going to go walk to first truck I
want to see a leopard on the rock are
you enter this entombed Adam no you're
going to carry on sleeping for now I see
hopefully she does wander down towards
first truck it's quite a few puddles on
top of the rock she might hit there for
a little drink and there are some Impala
with some babies not too far away from
first Rock as well I wonder where mom is
and aunt in Ghana as well I heard a
report that quarantine was around as
well promises don't boss the Little
Dipper doubt Ilana I doubt I could even
if I wanted to it looks like she is a
her mind made up and what she wants to
do it's news she's probably had a very
busy day
fiddling around this area what if you
spotted nothing okay well Daphne has
been a day full of cats so let's go back
to have a look at the Impala pride well
you know thinking about it we might have
struggled a little bit with various
gremlins that have been attacking and
attacking us but we have managed the big
cat trifecta this afternoon on the
Sunset Safari so it can't be all that
bad and very shortly I'm going to leave
the Inca home is and make my way towards
a the hyena den is a struggle always
when you know that lions are going to
get moving but there are quite large so
it could take them a while and I do have
stuff I need to do after the hyena den
so I need to head there I'm hoping
against hope that our they're going to
be out and about before it gets too dark
the Lions are thoroughly content now
they've had some water they've got full
bellies couldn't be better
adle you'd think so wouldn't you those
full bellies doll wants to know if full
bellies make hunting harder for them I
think they must have some effect you
know maybe even if it just takes a
little bit off their top speed but to be
honest I have seen Lions run at full
tilt with full bellies so it doesn't
seem to hold them back too much it might
make them more reluctant to go hunting
unless something strolls right into
their midst there are less likely to put
in the extra effort they can just spend
time digesting they don't need to stress
too much about a meal but you never know
with lions all of the big cats are
opportunists so something did happen
they would be well prepared to hunt and
it wouldn't hold them back immensely I
imagine it might make jumping a little
bit harder imagine jumping with a belly
that's a roughly 10% of your body weight
it sounds exhausting to me probably
quite stressful on the joints as well
there we go on that note speaking of
body weight Nancy wants to know how much
a fully grown lioness would weigh around
about a hundred and thirty a hundred and
forty odd kilograms of big really big
lioness might top the scales with a full
belly at one hundred and fifty so that's
just under three hundred pounds or so
would be a full the full weight of a
lioness they're big animals they are
really very very solid they are pure
muscle lipids also quite large
a lot more compact than you expect them
to be so even a tiny little leopard like
ton D probably weighs around about 40
kilograms or so
but that extra weight means that there
are somewhat muscle-bound they're not
quite as fast as a leopard when it comes
to short bursts of speed or quite as
agile they are strong alrighty I'm gonna
leave our lines I'm going to mosey on
along towards the hyena den Tristan is
experiencing the best part of the Mara
which of course is an evening storm and
downpour let's go see how he feels about
it
well we are we in the rain and it's
starting to really tank down now we did
have some marinas that were with us but
with the way that the rain is falling at
the moment is going to be very very
tricky to see anything you can see James
is trying to scan about trying to see
where they've gone but they've just
disappeared out of sight into the rain
and I'm trying to just scan with my
spotlights to see if I can help him
there they are there James I don't know
if you can come forward they're
somewhere in the darkness there and just
see eyes every now and then let me try
and find them again
to the left side think James there there
you can just see their eyes kind of in
the darkness so they use a bit of a
spotlight just help James for a bit but
you can see I eanes that are kind of
just creeping along through the darkness
it's just trying to put it a little bit
it really isn't easy when it's raining
like this you can see it's kind of
coming down quite a bit at the moment so
we're just trying to slowly kind of age
our way forward and haven't really put
our covers down correctly yet because it
just came out of nowhere I think we're
gonna get absolutely hammered by rain on
our way home tonight because there is a
very big dark black cloud to our
left-hand side and there's lightning
hammering down from that side so it's
gonna be a pretty uncomfortable journey
home tonight problem is is with these
things as I can't see anything when
this windscreen is up I'm trying to kind
of look around of these hyenas have gone
farther in the distance over there so
they kind of milling about on the side
at the moment they just sort of looking
for food I would imagine and to cause
them a bit of a nuisance you can see
this rain is all sort of piling off the
roof at the moment sorry James I don't
know there they are there and if your
infrared can only reach so far the
lights and so it's pretty tricky you in
these kind of situations when I eanes
walk away from us it makes life very
very difficult and poor James is trying
to get the best that he can but it
really isn't easy at all now the hyenas
will be probably quite happy because
there's a lot of both of these skeletons
that are lying around or dried out
wildebeest that have desiccated and so
with this kind of rain it will just
moisten them up a bit and there'll be a
few students and bits that they'll be
able to feed on and bite on and kind of
chew on and just do high English things
ready and so that's going to be quite
nice for them pretty sure that's what
they're doing is they're just gonna mela
bart and chew on things and hopefully
then if kenya makes a kill they will
benefit off that knot hopefully fast tom
for the simple reason is this because
you want to know why my windscreen
wipers are off because if I do that like
we normally Drive and fold the
windscreen well then you get what is
called a massive accident and the
windscreen breaks the windscreen wipers
and so we've done that a few times and
broken them and that's why we do not
have windscreen wipers unfortunately
because otherwise you break them every
time you push the window down and it's
far more pleasant to drive without a
windscreen up during dry periods and so
now it's just going to be a game of
trying to stay through water droplets as
we drive home which is a fun game it's
my favourite game not really at all
problem is is I'm going to have to close
this all up because I can't have any
forward momentum at all with arts
Emily andreas I need everything actually
I need a boat is what I need and a hole
and a drysuit and then I'll be happy and
then we won't get wet the problem is is
obviously the equipment get to it you
see I can't drive it all because
otherwise it's just it's funneling
straight in towards James and his stuffs
going to get old damp as well so we're
gonna have to close this car
unfortunately we can't carry on like
this
otherwise we're just going to get very
very very wet so while I do that's why I
cover up the car and get ourselves
sorted out it's in your back truster
print and Columba Columba is still
sitting in the same spot she has not
moved isn't she absolutely gorgeous
that little darling Columba I said I'm
hoping she does get up
sorry about that everyone apparently
brains disappeared of your screens
that's okay I'm here I'm around and we
are heading towards the hyena den so
everybody I think let's just keep very
hopeful that they are out and about
oh goodness gracious
there's something else blowing back in I
feel it definitely feels as though
there's more of the cold front passing
over us there's quite a substantial
front it covered quite a bit of the
country I see
those are old hyena tracks I'm hoping
that wherever Corky and frizzy are
they've had a good meal they were hungry
Wow porky was hungry actually haven't
seen pretty
keep thinking I'm seeing hyena tracks in
the dirt so no not a hundred percent
sure maybe I'm just really hopeful
because there's more rain coming and
it's going to come soon it's going to be
with us very shortly I think
which at least will make me feel better
about having the roof on definitely more
justified
is it crazy critter okay
crazy said oh quit so sorry I said crazy
Koki Franklin calling in there critter
says that it's amazing just how much
it's greened up with just that little
bit of rain it started with the rain on
I really noticed the difference look the
trees were going green but I really
noticed the difference on when was it
when was it that we had that big we had
the morning off and the big rainstorm
the night before it was at Wednesday was
Thursday I can't remember just hey Craig
what did you say was a Thursday
Wednesday Wednesday no was Wednesday
that's right
it was Wednesday yes so on Wednesday
there was a massive downpour and that's
when I noticed that even the next day it
seemed that much greener I say massive
there was twenty miles in two hours
which is quite a lot of rain I'm not I
was expecting with this front I was
expecting a bit more rain than we
received I don't think we received very
much at all in fact I even promised this
morning that I would look to see how
much rain we received and now I don't
think I've had any updates where's the
rain group
no I have I have we received well hold
on yes I have a rain group on whatsapp I
have all the groups 12 moles
I was spot on ha that's what I said this
morning
spot on where 12 moles yesterday I'm
very proud of myself that was exact once
I got something right with the weather
all right we're just gonna make our way
into the den while we do let's go back
across to Brent he's managed to find
some signal with Plummer and it's the
signal it just decided to disappear but
we're back and was still with the little
princess salamba and I hope things she's
gonna get moving she did spot some
Impaler not too far off however they
weren't interesting in her foyer she
decided to stay on top of her gym at
Mount Adele is wondering what is the
most skilled hunter of the cats lions
leopards or cheetahs
Adele they're all equally skilled in
their own right they have very different
tactics when it comes to hunting and it
would be unfair to compare them the best
ambush hunters and they will generally
only make the play at whatever they're
been stalking from about under 5 meters
as when a lipid leaps and they're very
quick and do about 24 meters per second
at that at that point and they cannot
keep it up for very long lions of course
big and powerful but also ambush hunters
but they can keep their speed going for
a little bit longer and they will tend
to charge from a bit further away and of
course cheetah is the kings of the speed
and they are able to chase for long
distances at very high speeds so they
all have very different techniques and
strategies so you can't actually compare
their hunting prowess that's very very
different
and see how little lamby is still
listening to everything that's going on
in watch her ears moving but alas I mean
we're hoping she might go try a dozen
parlor but unfortunately she decided not
Lidia would like to know how old shall
amber know when she's supposed to be
independent and honor her and well mom
will just keep smiling at her maybe even
actually smack her around a bit and that
is the time to no longer be a mommy's
girl and step out on your own and as
we've discussed in depth recently that
time is coming soon within the next
couple of months she will become an
independent leopard but for now mum is
still providing the meals that's not to
say she doesn't hunt a lot when she's
left by herself like this mostly it'll
be lots of little small things scrub
hairs franklin's squirrels dwarf
Mongoose and occasionally she might get
lucky and catch something as large as a
die-cut even a baby Impala but for now
it looks like she's going back to snooze
behind and that Oh chimney he popped a
head up again keep looking in the
direction of where that herd of Impala
is we can't see them I think they've
moved under there though Madhavi you see
this terminalia this a zoom now a little
bit to the right keep going slowly right
and zoom there you can pick up something
there we go a little bit up you can see
them moving through the bush so that's
where the Impala huh however she is not
showing any particular interest just yet
she might be waiting for it to get dark
oh she might just still be well enough
fed from the last few days
backed into T's very tired kitty achoo -
choo-choo so we've just heard from
Tristan I've been a Masai Mara
there's too much lightning around so he
has been forced to power down and
unfortunately so we're probably not
gonna see trusty again well you never
know you might find something in the
West on the way home and the Lightning
might have bet those storms can come in
very quickly and also dissipate very
quickly
my head's up again can't see anything
down there but she is a little busybody
hello Lily who's 7 years old
Lily would like to know whether lumber
will miss her mom when she has to leave
maybe for a little bit Lily but then she
has to learn how to be a big girl and
hunt by herself can hear some Bush fault
rain frog starting to make some noise
[Music]
and also here rattling sister giver
calling in the background
kiss-kiss run away kiss-kiss run away
but a little slumber is not showing
interest in anything
caryl six would like to know what in my
opinion what are the chances of tristan
joining the marshmallow club hi Carol hi
very high I think Tristan's going to get
stuck maybe not today but maybe tomorrow
a little bit lower than this time last
year because the small rains in the Mara
haven't been nearly as but as nearly as
big as they were last year or earlier
this year should I say rather I must
remember that this year it was the most
rain the Maasai Mara had had in 60 years
what are you doing silly cat - keeping
one eye on us
such a pretty little kitty the little
drama
Nachi girl is wondering what markings we
use to identify it well normally its
spot patterns which are the last line of
spots above the whiskers but with
salamba we just I just look at her
I don't really looking for any
distinguishing marketing's particularly
in this area it is the only leopard of
that age but I can show you what when I
talk about spot patterns what I mean so
a spot pattern is the last line of spots
above the whiskers there and said
lumbers got very distinct yeah five four
five
she always read the spots from the right
was it a four four I mean it's
advertised look I actually haven't
really looked at Columbus but pad number
four we can normally just spot who she
is by where she is and she's she's quite
distinct looking ahead shape is quite
different from that of her mom's
okay well we're gonna sit with a little
Shambo a little bit longer let's send
you across to Jamie to see what she's up
to now it's a hyena do miracles never
cease it's a hyena hooray hooray
break out the streamers and me whatever
else you happen to want to use it's a
hyena look I ain't as I'm looking for
but it's a hyena nevertheless I'll take
what I can get at this point and sneak a
pretty noir Corky I was hoping that they
were going to be at the den they weren't
let's see if it has a drink quickly
Oh God backwards a little bit looks like
it's be lying in bed all day so I don't
think it's going to have a drink here
right go back into the mud oopsie not
turn around hold on that's very pretty
right where you off to hi you know
you're going to go and fetch Corky and
pretty for me and take them to the den
would be nice if you would be so
obliging
ah man if only things know where we
going we're going down here you look
quite full actually
idea we've changed direction we're now
going into a drainage line so goodbye
hey net was nice it was fun
might coach the den though it's looking
like it's going to go in that direction
off you can't see it anymore
I think it just yet okay let's go around
we'll meet it on the other side and I'll
see if it goes to the den side maybe its
presence there will perk up Corki and
pretty and hello hello to Zack who is 9
years old and is wondering about when
hyenas move they move their den site did
I hear that correctly do cool so Zack
Zack wants to know if when they moved
ends do they do it at night yes usually
but they can move during the day as well
so it's most often they'll move at night
and if the Cubs are very small and the
mothers will carry them if they're not
very small than the mothers we'll get
them to walk with them it's obviously a
time when the Cubs are very very
vulnerable to other predators it's quite
dangerous for them because they're still
tiny and they don't run very fast and
there's nowhere really that they can
escape to so it can be quite dangerous
for the moving den Czar's going the
other way it's going up towards Pangolin
track let's see if we might still meet
on the road I'll see how far my signal
my vehicle signal stretches
what does also happen believe it or not
is that hyena Cubs have taken on little
expeditions where the mother or it's
sometimes a mother with several
different cubs not necessarily just her
own will lead the Cubs and the Cubs will
go with the mother and they'll explore a
little bit further outside of the den
site and then the mother will lead them
back to the den once their day is done
so kind of like a school field trip but
that happens when the Cubs are a little
bit older than the ones that are at the
juma clans den know we're going to den
just seen it going across that way hmm
well wonders never cease I saw it sucker
here this morning which was interesting
without Corky oh pretty he was out here
playing with the Cubs I was quite
surprised
I wonder what I saw going that way then
as it clearly wasn't the syena Succah is
a very popular male hyena news right
there is something sort of captain of
the rugby team asked about him
which way are we going it's hyena will
pop into view in a moment I just had to
do some shuffling because of the roof
are we gonna go to the den come on go
find Corki please go find Corki I'm
rapidly running out of light for what I
need to do okay cool let's catch up just
going to do something quickly before I
do it in the presence of the Cubs and
give them a fright there we go I won't
like that very much no animal likes the
sound of velcro
apparently including humans according to
the lady's infernal control that's it if
we go
well done muddy hyena you've obviously
had a good day wallowing Oh a lovely
thing about a hyena den is that it
really is the social hub of the clan
hyenas that have no curbed as males
whatever it happens to be we'll come and
visit the den on a regular basis
particularly when there's high ranked
individuals with Cubs at the den
okay let's see what happens because I
might have got as you know I can't sit
at the den when there's no females there
but it's really tricky because I know
that at any point Corky and pretty could
arrive so it's difficult I feel
comfortable approaching when there is
another adult here though except it's
going the wrong way no it was coming
back please don't just walk straight
past the den I will stop I will weep
there's no sign of the adults just see
which side this hyena goes and is going
to go to that entrance all right I love
that's cool Jonathan I'm really glad to
hear that Jonathan tells us that he now
has sympathy for hyenas they certainly
deserve a bit more respect than they are
often given there's more to them than
the oversimplification that is voiced
sit upon them hey girl yeah hello good
morning you are a welcome sight for sore
eyes but I cannot do what I need to do
with you as lovely as you are sniff
sniff sniff sniff sniff
I'm just gonna take my earpiece out for
one second
I thought I heard an Impala alarm call
but it must be
the wind's blowing a little bit I can't
hear properly
I was hoping that the presence of this
hyena might just encourage Corky and
pretty to make a reappearance wherever
they are suspect that they were eating
given the size of the belly on this
individual having a sniff around to see
whether or not this dentist or actor but
a completely different approach to the
one to the approach of a mother that is
coming to fetch the cubs no real
interest shown in calling which of
course makes sense got nothing to call
for
my thing a little bit further see the
Cubs are encouraged to come out you know
it makes me think about what I've just
said about Cubs moving to insights ah
Thank You crystal this is apparently
causa not a hundred percent of a with
the males yet I honestly haven't had the
time to sit and memorize them so I know
it sucker and I know Luca because he's
very easy to identify
I don't know comet and I'm I'll have to
double to make sure that I learned cause
I cuz I didn't actually know it was him
Thank You Rosa
where are where are the mothers of these
Cubs while we wait to see whether or not
they emerge out of the growing gloom
let's go across to a column now that
brent is prepared to be able to film in
the dark
yes we're just putting on our infrared
lights don't need them just yet but it's
always better to be prepared she still
has not moved much all very happy on top
of her to a materia waiting patiently
for mum
Maurice is wondering do any of the big
cats shed their claws like the domestic
cat that will lose court claws when they
are fighting or hunting and they do grow
back so I suppose they do shed but not
quite the same as the the smaller cat
species
where is Tandy Kalama where's your mom
why is she not bringing you your dinner
so from what I heard yesterday
unfortunately for Andy and Columba
Tenggara arrived during the day at some
point and made off and with that little
Impala kill they had so it wasn't a big
kill to start off with
what are you doing you're giving you
myself a little clean before wandering
off or you going to keep only going to
keep snoozing
are we going to flop down are we going
to get up mm what do you think David I
think flop yes I think she's too
interested in doing too much
Angora is wondering how far away from
being a fully grown adult is lumber no
she still got a quite a bit of growing
to do she'll probably only reach her
full size at just over two years two and
a half years old maybe even grow all the
way to three
and she's interested in something again
almost looks understandably possibly
coming back or as an Impala in inverted
leap one did up to her termite mound
just trying to swing through
yes I thought it was a big tree
somewhere I didn't want to drive into
[Music]
she's lost interest in whatever it was
again
what are you looking at I don't see
anything
that's what the most movement she's made
all afternoon
now we're probably gonna leave shortly
let me see what she does
we do have infrared capabilities and
I've got a feeling she's not gonna do
too much yeah we're about to switch into
infrared cat as it is getting dark are
you doing with your tail tupid why are
you biting your own tail
no it'll play with you so you bought
your own tail
isn't that pretty
what you going to do now I'm going to
curl up into another ball yes that's
what we're going to do in to curl up and
give us the cold shoulder so I'll she
gives us the cold shoulder let's send
you back to Jamie well speaking of the
cold shoulder well the good news is that
the hyenas not they are not playing well
at the moment it's interesting I don't
know if it's the late summer hours or
what it is but we're just not seeing
them as often as we were around but then
I suppose the Cubs are a little bit
older so they don't need feeding as
often as they did when they were little
little all right well it was worth a try
I'll pop back if I see any sign of
activity around but otherwise I'm going
to go back track causa
where he came from and see whether or
not he perhaps got lucky and maybe
Hassan is around there and that's why
cause is so full we'll go find out it's
really a shot in the dark but we haven't
got anything else to go on the ground is
so hard at the moment the tracks are
very difficult to see it's really all we
have right now Tristan's gone I can't go
much further than this area the Hainan
dens about as far as I can go before I
go over a dip and then my signal
disappears so we will go for it we will
approach it with great enthusiasm
actually you know what I'm gonna do is
what time is that I might make my way
back towards those lions and we'll spend
the rest of the afternoon with them I'm
pretty sure I can get back to them in
time should we give it a go let's give
it a go
we have to only hopes and one is more
secure than the other all right
let us leave low range and off we go
cool
all righty we've got our FLIR all pips
and ready to go
safari saw me know it's one of the nicer
aspects of hyena society although I will
counter that to the flipside in a moment
but no male Highness will not harm Cubs
that are not their own Edward a late
explosion it would completely counter
act the way that hyena society works
where the male's actually have to be
very friendly and very approachable
towards females in order for them to
have a chance to mate so killing Cubs
does not happen really with males in
hyena society but females do kill Cubs
that are not their own and are not
related to them nobody quite knows why
they do it some do it more than others
but that it does happen so the flipside
instead of being killed by the male's
they are sometimes killed by the females
particularly where a low ranked cub
oversteps its boundaries and in some way
traumatized as a high ranked cub and the
mother just steps in and that's the end
of of the little low-ranked covered
terribly tragic I haven't seen it happen
often
fortunately never seen it happen with
the Juma clan hello amber Lala's coming
through I'm going to try and get to the
Lions before the end of the drive
are there any stations still the Inca
homers
yeah - if you go to than on the northern
side of where teller Dam and you take
that little link road that runs the West
they were right there
no negative it is southeast of where
they were but if you take the road that
runs north of the big boy attila dam and
you go west from there
let's try this again
what's your position now
okay copy perfect before you get to the
voyeurs main exit you take that road
that runs to the left
I'm making my way as well I'm coming
from the main access road
shame the poor dude he he can't find
them I can I think I see his lies
I'll give him a hand see we were gonna
kill two birds with one stone
we'll help help a fellow friend and we
will go back to the lines
hold on everyone
we're gonna make its meaning get there
before the end of drive okay
how's it fish yeah cool
enjoy have a good evening you see you
later
13 minutes to get there I think we can
do it in under five to be quite honest
I'd really think we can slap my nose
alright so back in the day we used to
hold on I was going to say I used to
pick up the final control ladies from
the where the the final control used to
be which was away from our main camp and
I used to give them countdowns to time
when they had to leave the building and
come out to the road and I used to pride
myself on getting it exact whether it
was 3 minutes and 15 seconds or whether
it was 40 seconds I used to count all
the way down until I got there and I
always managed to get it right
probably because I was the one doing the
counting down and therefore could bias
that completely into the right direction
or stretch it out slightly to make it
fit and and of course inducing complete
panic for the ladies who are desperately
trying to shut everything down
ah everything's attacking me dung
beetles flies
it's been two minutes I said I'd do it
in under five irate I will do it in a
school where they were in next 35 he
stopped there
nevermind I'll take take that out of the
equation I can't I can no longer give an
accurate time for it is no longer
dependent purely upon my actions
I cannot account for this speed of
others
okay
all righty one two three four five six
feel like I've missed something because
I said there were four adults in one
sub-adult but there's six lions here
what did I miss
who did I not count did I miss one of
the sub adults who is it all five or
five lions well there's six here now
there were only five one two three four
one two three four five now I'm going
crazy
oh one two three four five six another
six lines here and by the way that
that's about over on the left there
Craig ran to greet the one that's just
behind her yes that one over there it
was with great excitement and affection
did I miss something
odd rupees so nice if it were a full
Informer reunion
that would be really lovely but I think
I just must count it I don't know how I
really don't remember seeing six minuses
maybe one was lying up somewhere and we
just didn't spot her well grumpy grumpy
you've got your claws in my skin they're
not very pleasant at all
do you feel as though I'm losing my mind
slightly I don't feel like a lioness has
emerged from out of nowhere and yet and
yet
Thank You child of the universe's is
helping me out to this apparently they
really were only five this morning and
this afternoon so I'm not going
completely crazy I really I thought I
was going a little bit losing my mind a
little bit he would definitely only five
so where did the six Linus come from I
have absolutely no idea that is a
complete mystery to me she's also quite
full but not as full as the others and
where's the rest of a pride perky you
noticed that the ones Bailey was not
quite as full as the others yes that I
think is the one that just came in it's
now dark which means that identifying
them becomes a little bit harder at
least certain individuals I'm really
hoping it's going to be all of the Lions
reuniting but there doesn't seem to be
any sign of that happening just the one
- that's just suddenly popped out of
nowhere now I've lost one again one two
three four five I think the other ones
gone behind the pan that's so
interesting - with a blind eye you can
barely see any reflection of the
infrared it's not the one of the blind I
think it is must be because there's
absolutely no response from the pupil
there she is a bit grumpy
she keeps snarling at the sub-adults
who's just full of the joys of youth it
seems a little bit unpleasant it comes
another lioness not another I mean the
one that was a bit lagging a bit behind
she gonna come in they really are not
what I remembered in terms of the
affection thing coomer's used to show to
each other everyone so snarly
we used to watch this pride greet each
other with sheer joy now they're all
sort of I mean they still lie together
and rub heads but everybody's a bit on
edge
shame ladies it had been a traumatic few
months
mm-hmm child of the universe I don't
know if this has been made official
official by anyone I don't suppose
there's any one who makes it official
but yes I would say that Juma would now
be considered to be a solid firm part of
the Avoca males territory absolutely
they have encountered no resistance
they've been mating with females right
in the center of Duma yes I think it's
safe to say the tumors now belongs to
the Evo cos for now male coalitions come
and go but the prides stay the same now
that one missing adult was the one with
the injury on her hip because I
definitely haven't seen her today so to
be interesting to see if that one that
came in and had the injury but I can't I
can't tell because I haven't seen the
right side of her well the left side but
the side that I need to see I'm sure I
haven't seen Oh today oh these dynamics
are sufficient to keep us all guessing I
really don't 100% know exactly what's
going on within corners 11 is not too
large a pride number to necessitate a
split I wouldn't have thought
when you start getting into the sort of
number of lines being over 20 that's a
different story
I don't know perhaps to keep the young
male safe I'm really not sure
it's all very confusing because although
the sabado females
I would say are probably going to be
okay now he's still at risk with a group
of incoming new males very confusing
here's that other line is gone now oh
she's coming up from the right she's
going oh sorry she's going to come and
join them she just went to relieve
herself
he looks so cool I'm looking at it
through the eyes of the view bro and it
looks so so it
nope oh sorry I keep putting my head in
the way you duck down properly I just
keep trying to look at where they are in
real life and a lot of you wondering if
I know where the rest of the pride is no
I really don't have a clue I'm gonna
post a message on one of them multiple
whatsapp groups that helps to keep track
of where the animals are and see if
anybody has any answers for us I'm
really curious to know hopefully some
other guides and some neighboring
properties have some answers and I'll
let you know tomorrow on the Sunrise
Safari it would really help if we could
get that information and get a breakdown
of who is where Carlyle a very good
question Carlyle wants to know the
differences between a pride and a
coalition a very fundamental difference
a pride is made up of females and their
offspring including male offspring up to
about the age of three years old and
Coalition is a group of males
now males either establish territory on
their own which is very difficult to do
or they form at a group with relatives
or with other males from the surrounding
area and they establish a territory that
encompasses the territory of other pride
members so of several different prides I
mean so males are not actually part of
the pride itself they are entirely
separate to it something that people
often get confused about because that's
not the way we've been taught to think
of lions and their social structure just
by the way if you're wondering about the
lights in the background of Terra just
popped up it is because we're right
outside the lodge so imagine some of the
guests are going to be having a dinner
at a Galago tonight and listening to the
sounds of the Lions not too far away
from them
come on ladies show a little bit of
affection for each other it's my my
favorite thing about lions well we can
only guess how things are going to play
out at least we've got some of the Inca
home a pride to keep us company it has
been a challenging but lovely sunset
Safari we of course appreciate all of
you we appreciate your patience as well
as we've dealt with certain technical
difficulties we're very grateful for
that tomorrow morning will bring a new
start to the day and who knows what